bonsoir qualité
merci d'être avec nous une impression
générale de la réunion de jeudi sur le
nucléaire iranien
positive nous dit-on mais qui sera suivi
d'un certain nombre de réunions
informelles à quoi vous le spécialiste
de l'iran vous attendez-vous pour ses
prochaines réunions
je pense qu'il est important c'est que
ces discussions aient commencé qu'elles
se poursuivent en dépit de toutes les
déclarations
l'iran reste dans l'accord de 2015 c'est
faut pas l'oublier est donc l'objectif
est toujours le même c'est un retour
coordonnée des états unis dans l'accord
techniquement c'est pas très compliqué
il faut que les deux pays se mettent
d'accord pour d'un côté les états unis
lèvent les sanctions qui ont été
réimposées par trump peut partir de mai
2018 et que l'iran revienne sur toutes
les mesures qu'ils ont prises à partir
de la mi-2010 9 pour sortir de l'accord
vous détenez pas compliqué voilà ça n'a
pas l'air non plus très simple l'iran en
tout cas la réclame cette levée des
sanctions
pourquoi ça ne va pas plus vite non mais
techniquement j'ai dit c'est pas
compliqué politiquement c'est autre
chose
d'un côté vous avez quand même aux états
unis joe biden doit faire face à
beaucoup d'opposition que ce soit dans
le parti républicain même dans son
propre parti démocrate
un instant de groupes qui sont contre
simplement un retour des etats-unis dans
l'accord qui sont contre la levée des
sanctions
donc ça posait ça lui posait pas parce
qu'il a besoin du congrès par rapport
ils veulent y doit faire voter son plan
de relance et c'est donc il
en gros il doit faire passer cette
pilule a donc il faut qu'ils prennent
des formes et du côté iranien
c'est pas rien les relations avec les
états unis on va dire ça
l'opposition aux états lycée on est au
coeur idéologique de la république
islamique d'iran donc la réplique
islamique d'iran peut pas comme ça
montrer qu'elle est d'un coût y tout va
bien que les etats-unis qui en plus en
plus il ya une énorme méfiance vous avez
des etats-unis en iran il faut rappeler
quand même l'iran respecté l'accord les
états unis en sortent sans raison à
partir de mai 2018 donc il ya eu déjà il
ya cette hostilité naturel aux états
unis
q c'était leur méfiance et le fait que
ce sont les radicaux au pouvoir en iran
donc et aussi des questions de politique
intérieure en iran mais je répète
techniquement c'est pas très compliqué à
mettre en place et je trouve c'est quand
même très important qu'en dépit de ce
que disent les deux pays les discussions
commencées et en dépit de ce qui vient
de se passer l'iran reste dans ces
discussions c'est ça qui est important
alors il ya quand même quelques
obstacles avaient dit qu'ils sont avant
tout politiques la décision notamment de
l'iran d'enrichir l'uranium à hauteur de
60%
c'est de nature à inquiéter tout de même
c'est une information qu'on peut faire
entrave
évidemment tout de suite
et d'ailleurs c'est l'objectif recherché
par l'iran en parlant de 60%
ils font peur dans le sens on s'approche
des 90 % qui sont la limite technique
auquel on commence à fabriquer des armes
nucléaires
d'un autre côté il faut quand même
rappeler que cette annonce de l'iran est
vieille et vient tout de suite après
l'attaqué terroriste le contrôle les
indh en attente manifestement qui vient
d'israël donc je pense que du côté
iranien
il utilise l'enrichissement d'uranium
comme moyen de pression dans les
négociations
je pense jeudi ils sont toujours autant
ces négociations c'est pour eux c'est
une manière de mettre la pression
notamment sur les états unis et je le
répète il faut pas oublier que s'il
avait voulu quitter l'accord ils ont
très bien pu faire le guide aurait très
bien pu décider depuis mai 2018 va être
mis en fuite l'accord ils y sont
toujours
donc c'est vrai que c'est inquiétant un
compte tenu du fait que le niveau
d'enrichissement le quai à 3 67% dans
l'accord de 2015 la is a long 60 % ils
annoncent ils n'ont pas commencé
je pensais plutôt une tactique pour
mettre la pression notamment ceux des
états unis pour pour ces négociations
en tout cas c'est d'être rassurant et
déclare que ses activités nucléaires de
l'iran sont pacifiques à répondre et ce
que nous dit l'iran depuis des années
maintenant est ce qu'on peut vraiment le
croire
écoutez pour compte s'ils voulaient
faire la bombe du caire pourquoi ils ont
signé l'accord et 2015
je pose une question m je crois qu'en
quand donald trump prend la décision
j'ai déjà dit sur votre antenne 2 de
sortir de l'accord ans
2018 je crois qu'il ya un an aux
rapports 11 rapport de l'agencé
internationale d'énergie atomique qui
est chargée de vérifier l'application
d'accords qui certifie que l'on respecte
l'accord et l'accord donné toutes les
garanties pour que le programme
nucléaire iranien reste pacifique
jusqu'à la fin de l'accord je crois
qu'ils aient 2025
donc voilà la réponse est là et l'iran
n'a pas quitté l'accord en dépit du fait
qu'elle est la principale un acteur
important que les états unis a sorti de
l'accord je rappelle sans raison et amis
remis en place des sanctions qui ont
dévasté l'économie iranienne donc les
rangs et toujours dans l'accord
easy tienne c'est très important pour
eux et donc je pense que si vous voulez
faire la bombe atomique qui serait déjà
sortis de la corde je crois d'ailleurs
en plus bon l'agencé internationale
d'énergie atomique disait clients
respecter l'accord je crois qu'elle
vient d'avoir un rapport de toutes les
agences de de sécurité américaines qui
pensent qu'à leur avis alors que l'iran
ne cherche toujours pas à aller vers l'
arme atomique
il utilise je le répète l'enrichissement
d'uranium comme moyen de pression et ce
qu'ils demandent finalement c'est le
retour aux études et à lui dans l'accord
qui garantit que le problème nucléaire
iranien mais ceci reste aux civils merci
beaucoup thierry coville chercheur à
l'iris spécialiste de l'iran d'avoir été
avec nous vous avez remporté votre
analyse